[Music]
good afternoon
and uh good to meet you virtually in the
european commission's
press room welcome to the press
conference on the results of the
negotiations between the european union
and the united kingdom
on their future a relationship this
press conference
is in the presence of european
commission president ursula fonda lyon
as well as our chief negotiator
michel barnier president fonder lion
will
make a statement as well afterwards
uh mr barnier following that we will
take
a few questions and we will offer you
the possibility of a technical briefing
with our experts who
held the negotiations um over
those many months where you can ask many
many questions
but before that allow me to give the
floor to
president for the line yes thank you
good afternoon
so we have finally found an agreement
it was a long and winding road but
we have got a good deal to show for it
it is fair it is a balanced deal
and it is the right and responsible
thing to do for both sides
negotiations
let me give you three examples first of
all
competition in our single market will be
fair
and remain so the eu rules and standards
will be respected we have effective
tools to react
if fair competition is distorted and
impacts our trade secondly
we will continue cooperating with the uk
in all areas of mutual interest
for example in the field of climate
change
energy security and transport
together we still achieve more than we
do apart
and thirdly we have secured five and a
half
years of full predictability for our
fishing communities
and strong tools to incentivize
to remain so of course
this whole debate has always been about
sovereignty
we should cut through the sound bites
and ask ourselves
what sovereignty actually means in the
21st century
for me it is about being able
to seamlessly do work travel study
and do business in 27 countries
it is about pooling our strength and
speaking together
in a world full of great powers
and in a time of crisis it is about
pulling each other up instead of trying
to get back to your feet alone
and the european union shows how this
works in practice and no deal in the
world
can change reality or gravity in today's
economy
and today's world we are one of the
giants
the european union is
foreign
[Music]
so now is the time to turn the page
and look to the future the united
kingdom
is a third country but it remains a
trusted partner
we are long-standing allies
we share the same value and interests
whether it be the cop 26 summit in
glasgow
or the upcoming uk g7
and italian g20 presidencies
the european union and the united
kingdom will stand
shoulder to shoulder to deliver on our
common global goals
your
i also want to thank david frost and
tim barrow for having been tough
but fair negotiating partners and i'm
grateful to all our member states and
the european parliament
for their trust and their support
i will now convene the college
and ladies and gentlemen at the end of a
successful negotiations
journey i normally feel joy
but today i only feel
quite satisfaction and frankly speaking
relief i know
this is a difficult day for some
and to our friends in the united kingdom
i want to say
parting is such sweet sorrow
but to use a line from t s eliot
what we call the beginning is often the
end
and to make an end is to make a
beginning so to all europeans i say
it is time to leave brexit behind our
future is made in europe thank you so
much
thank you very much president now allow
me to give the floor to our chief
negotiator
michelle barnier
thank you madam president diverse
the clock is no longer ticking
after four years of collective effort
and eu
unity to preserve peace and stability on
the island of ireland
to protect the citizens and the single
market
to build a new partnership with the uk
thank you all thank you all this is the
work of so many women and men
here in the commission under your
leadership madam the president
all the services and in particular the
eu task force
for the brexit with clara martinez
and paulina deschmeck and all the team
and in the member states the council
the european parliament
i also paid tribute also to the
eu uk negotiating team
and the chief negotiator david frost and
his deputies this process
has engaged so many citizens
businesses stakeholders and
obviously so many journalists
thank you for your patience and for your
attention
today is a day of relief
but instead by some sadness
as we compare what came before
with what lies fred
europe
the renault
free and fair trade fair and free trade
santa if nicota your currency taco
the nouvelle regular economic
level playing field in europe
the new generation
repartition
foreign
um
indeed uh we had already built in the
withdrawal agreement
uh strong measures in case uh that the
withdrawn
agreement is not being applied properly
uh the infringement procedure for
example that we started
and the same mechanisms are in this
agreement that we have strong measures
that can be taken
if one party does not play by the rules
so starting from rebalancing mechanisms
that are built in with dispute
settlement mechanism
uh to review clauses and an overall
review for example after four years to
see
whether both sides play by the rules
uh that the level playing field is level
indeed
and there's the commitment um to to
follow whatever has been agreed in this
um in this deal so from the experience
we've had we built in safeguards
that are necessary to make sure that
there's a strong incentive
for both sides to stick to what they
have agreed to
i will now give the floor to verena from
depe
verena are you there
so we are waiting for verna to get
connected
yes can you hear me now yes yes very go
ahead
yes great excellent thank you very much
for the question and
good afternoon to the president and mr
ban ki bengi
[Applause]
given the extreme time pressure toward
the end of these negotiations and
the deadline being only seven days away
are you confident that you really
say guarded all the interests of the
union and
of its member states or did you have to
give in
to british demands just to avoid
disaster
a week from now thank you very much
we had a very strong negotiating
position
indeed you're right the time was very
very short
at the beginning of the year we have
already said very clearly that for
such a comprehensive agreement um
12 months are really short really short
and on top
came covered this did not make the
negotiations more easy
and therefore it is outstanding what the
negotiating team has
done and achieved in only 12 months
that is one part um and our negotiating
position was as strong because
it was the european union who said very
clear
if the united kingdom wants access to
the single market the largest single
market in the world
uh without quota and without tariffs
then
um they are as a sovereign country free
to decide
whether they play by the rules like
every other company in
the single market too this is the level
playing field
if they do not want uh to follow the
rules then there will be quota
tariffs um so there is a price to pay
for that um and as we knew in any case
if there would have been a hard brexit
it would not have been good for both
sides but it would have hit the united
kingdom harder
than the european union with all its
might of 450 million citizens
and therefore from a position of
strength we were able
to come forward with the most
comprehensive
agreement we've ever had this agreement
will write history
if you look at the clear composition
of rules that are very distinct
to make sure that there's fair play on
both sides
that is a very clear if you want to
access the single market
you have to abide to the rules all the
other ones are abiding too
and in the fishery field i think we made
a huge
step forward and got a very good
agreement
so this shows that from a position of
strength you can achieve a lot
thank you very much president i know
that you have to go and inform the
college
there is interest for additional
questions but we have a technical
briefing
where all the questions will be
addressed so thank you so much
thank you so much for joining us in the
european commission's
press room for this press conference and
stay tuned for the technical briefing
of the record which will follow in a few
minutes
[Music]
you